is said to be investing hundreds of
thousands of dollars in virtual reality
films and programs including the
recruiting of some popular stars from
the web it's all part of its new
daydream service it's rolling out in the
next couple of weeks Bloomberg's tech
reporter Lucas Shaw joins my colleagues
pin Fox and Lisa Bromwich radio and I've
tried some and they are amazing but you
know one of the other things is they
don't necessarily have a lot of content
well I want to welcome all of our
Bloomberg television viewers right now
we're talking about virtual reality and
a rollout of a virtual reality platform
by Google they're also spending a lot of
money here to tell us more as lucas shaw
bloomberg news joining us from our San
Francisco Bureau and Lucas Shum what if
you could just describe what exactly is
Google doing in the virtual reality
space because they've got competitors I
mean Facebook is in VR as well as
Samsung and Sony yeah so Google's main
initiative main priority is this thing
called daydream which is a hybrid store
and operating service so just like
Android or iOS are the services that
make your phone run that will be
daydream for the the headsets that use
Google VR it's also a store and that if
you want to download an app or watch a
movie you'll access that through
daydream what makes Google a little bit
different from someone like Facebook
that you mentioned is that Google is
going through of your mobile phone it
wants a lot of different phones that run
the Android operating system or instead
of requiring the people who make phones
that have Android to update their phone
so that they can handle VR and handle
daydream so that anyone with an Android
phone could buy a headset from lots of
different makers and plug in their their
Android phone and then access that all
through daydream Lucas I'm looking at
projections that augmented our virtual
reality revenues could hit 150 billion
dollars by 2020 are we talking about
virtual reality of video games I mean
what could possibly spur this kind of
revenue generation
well this content of some kind whether
it'll be it seems like everybody
believes video games will be the kind of
the first way in the first thing to
attract people because a lot of the
initial virtual reality
at sets have been designed or created by
gamers but there are those investments
being made in short films in 360 degree
videos and then there's all sorts of
industries that are more and of
commercial businesses that people think
could be useful for VR whether it's that
excuse me that VR could be useful for
whether its retail real estate you know
medicine that's not something I've
reported on as much but there are a lot
of different applications with Google
though if they're looking for a phone
driven virtual reality experience and
you talking about headsets is there
gonna be a headset attached to your
phone yeah you plug your phone into a
headset so Samsung makes something
called the gear VR that's where you can
take your Samsung Galaxy and put that in
to the Samsung headset to use it
Samsung is actually a partner of
Google's as are a lot of other big
hardware makers so you'll take your
Google phone and you'll plug it into a
headset that is either made by Google
because they are working on one or made
by any number of other companies